now usually it's [ __ ] Rock Monday it's
[ __ ] Rock Friday why it's been a long
time since the I like fat tip Friday
yeah hot on a Friday fat tip Friday yeah
this is why this is why I always tell
people I had I had dinner with very
sophisticated people last night and I
they were like your podcasts it goes no
no look at me no no he's done not for
you not for you not for you dude how
about one just amazing artist see
otherwise like this asset management guy
family friends amazing how about my mom
calls me up she goes can you send me a
picture of the baby Boston right getting
chubby oh that's nice emigrate I posted
she bringing up channel Instagram my mom
just respond back thick so I called are
your geez mom is so cute or I'll kiss
him right now he's ridiculously a thick
just thick but how about my mom I know
what's going on mom she was oh nothing
just a [ __ ] rock Thursday really I'm
like god bless you mom you just can't I
bless you can't please not do that can
you please not do that
oh my god it's ridiculous enough how are
the holidays dude yeah once I soon we
saw each other well it's a lot on the
fan but it's been a while holidays were
interesting holidays are always fun as I
spent a lot of time with my kids it's
all good I was in Utah with my parents
so like all good yep yeah yep didn't do
any skiing don't ski no but the kids do
and not for me
scheme well you know our boy Todd broke
his femur skiing he broke his tibia not
futile front well that's not good at all
he's in some [ __ ] yeah a guy was killed
on the slopes
throughout 20 year old terrible coming
down slopes hit a tree
intermediate so happens everything about
their sunny yeah that was every [ __ ]
year somebody dies yeah
skiing but overall very crowded bit but
fun yeah what else nothing do nothing
nothing I was so sick you were sick I
didn't have the flu I have the cold I'd
like pneumonia like my lungs really hit
me okay that's not like you to talk
about you like you can be in a lot of
pain you'll never tell anybody because
never what's to be done
when's last time I had that told you can
do a show was last time I didn't do a
show never I know and I was like dude
I'm telling
can't come in I can't that's right you
could he couldn't do the parts right
that's why we're like we're gonna take a
short break anyways we never take this
long of a break right I physically
couldn't do the podcast I like I
couldn't do that my chest had so much
inflammation and my throat was gone it
was it was insane dude um when I was in
Boston had a great show Wilbur then I'm
with my boy Moloch it was my feature I'm
gonna see [ __ ] hilarious what is this
last weekend this is this is this Friday
this past New Year's Eve confusing so so
um my boy Bryan Cooley who has a justice
school in in Nashville he's six six and
he was a ranger before this he's a big
guy who's a competitive he competes but
he's just a giant Viking man so I'm with
I'm with I'm with Bryan cool he he flew
up there yeah he flew up there with his
wife Natalie awesome yeah good friends
look real whiskey guy okay real [ __ ]
whiskey guy next time you there'll be a
judge for that so um so I got Bryan
there
I got Moloch who came out of who has
been boxing since he was seven came out
of Floyd Mayweather's camp does he'll
out you know and then I got Lex Friedman
who does Rogan he's the guy who does the
deals with the robotics and the Tesla's
for you on Musk
he's the MIT professor yeah it's black
belt in judo and jujitsu okay and then
my boy Rob Bradley who's a black belt in
jujitsu as well so I'm I'm rolling kind
of deep with some big fellas Rob's big
you know six just I think I like to meet
a lot of me it's not like the nerdy
version of it I'm the nerdy I'm the
nerdy version I've heard avenge correct
yeah now my boy mouse got his beautiful
Ethiopian girl okay yeah chocolate yes
my other boy Justin's got his Eritrean
girl night Eritrea is the country that's
above Ethiopia there but beautiful women
in that part of the world she know I
she's not they're both black so Hank you
the mo Thank You Boaz is Moloch in love
or just duck it so so now now we're
dancing a me and Moloch -27 we're having
a dance-off we're right at the bar at
this club right near the W but being
silly kidding I wish you weren't dancing
but everybody was I'm the old guy having
a dance of a mug joking around [ __ ] but
we're having a [ __ ] silly time just
did a show I'm just having a good time
be an idiot now this is going to
you fighting gets batters out fight you
if I sell you dancing now I'm noticing
that this guy these these men who I
reckon you know how I can pick out
nationalities right away oh yeah and
that's I've ever seen them yep
there are therefore African gentlemen
and I happen to clock him and I go those
guys are clearly from Ethiopia and
they're staring you down well they're
now remember my boys with an Ethiopian
gal who I'm one of them's drunk and he
starts kind of walking up to the girls
that were with and they're getting kind
of one guys getting kind of grabby now
hold on
yeah I just try and paint this now you
know hey now I know you behold on these
Ethiopian me when I think Ethiopians
yeah because we're where I come from yes
bring up Ethiopian food a small and
skinny that's right Bret okay that's
right Bret 57.72 a man now knows I'm
Alice there beautiful people remember
these people gorgeous but five small
they're typically not trying they're not
giant no they tend to be slight there's
that there you go they're they're small
good knocking now let's I'm treading
lightly here that the one are they also
the same or it may be one get confused
with Somalia pirates where I'm the
captain now okay so that would be
Somalia which is next to Ethiopia very
modern culture okay one is Muslim the
other Coptic Christian I'm saying do
they look similar yes no East African
it's it's very very diverse racially
actually crushing like women not so much
East Africa's got really different
looking people right back the story so I
feel else I'd try I'm just I'm glad but
but if you look at that like small or
very smaller afield yes very fine
features and small there you go that's a
classic example you think very
good-looking people known for their look
yes okay now these guys because they've
been Americanized a little heavy and not
so good-looking and kind of shitty in
general now here's why now I'm rolling
with skinny fat building fuel be yeah
and I'm rolling with I'm rolling with
some American black guys who aren't
hearing a peep
no and yeah we're talking about the
other side of Africa by the way probably
ancestrally West African which is
different thing and now I got giant
Viking white guy I got I got Russian guy
and lady's American
I got big Irish guy my buddy Eric in
these are Americans okay you understand
although Lex is Russian now so so now
but you know you know oh Bry Bryson
secure and get super hot headed now
situation just lost laws what and the
less skilled correct right I am glad you
said it
who's the first gotta fight honestly
scale with you Ryan
the Chihuahua most into our most
insecure the old scalawag Chihuahua
Ricky by the way my name is rink so
thank you very much sorry man
alright I mean everywhere I go thanks
I'm getting screamed out in the whole
foods for God's sake in [ __ ] Utah I
get to Park City right like I walk in
rags if its dude oh my god
Jesus Christ there it is and I'm walking
I hear about the counter raves that's my
name so serene statue ah WA starts the
bar key so I I and I yeah I like words I
like somebody knows how to use word yeah
so this guy is now all of a sudden music
stops and this guy looks right at my
bookmark and goes hey that's our sister
man that's our sister you shouldn't be
with our sister oh and I go what and he
goes man shut up you don't know if the
pho I go I go the [ __ ] you talk now I'm
numb and now they're getting their
posturing now Malik Malik literally you
could be awesome
he doesn't give a [ __ ] he's like he's
literally he's already diffused three
fights he could give a [ __ ]
he's so such a goofball he's not even
noticing the areas there is hilarious oh
look at him lifting away so I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] him up for that is
that he's so high the way one of us a
silly goose all lives only to be a silly
good okay so now he's not even he's not
giving him anything and I'm like what
the [ __ ] oh that's this is so figure so
he has no [ __ ] these Brian Brian this is
how Brian could diffuse to tell me you
looked everywhere I'm the captain now I
didn't say [ __ ] Brian just got what I
would have said coolly goes like this
Kui goes hey bro you know jaws and the
guy goes y-yes jaws in the movie no job
have accents yeah they not they have the
accents but they spoke very valid names
you got goes yeah and he goes
you're the girl enjoy swimming in the
water does how to swim she's got no idea
there's a shark gonna pull him under I'm
the calm the shark I'm gonna pull you
under it was the greatest [ __ ] thing
and he's so big and and he's just like
sitting there looking up I'm the
shakopee you're the girl in charge swim
think I gave him the thumbs off this
bucket took a look and they're like ah
this is a bath it should be a very bad
it was so [ __ ] great from the shore
it was so great it was great he was he's
just he's so big and intimidating
military guys it's like oh god yeah
you know what's crazy I love that you
know what's crazy is when people that
like that happens and they don't read
the situation and they keep going it's
like oh are you [ __ ] because they're
drunk or they actually think poor just
it's like happen you've never had
anybody do that to you though right no
not really
I mean but there are people myself I'll
hang out well that you know what I did I
don't think it came out of like 'man you
say it all I'm especially in Posten dude
New Year's what are you doing so how
about correct are you doing what am i
doing wrong I said it now listen um we
came up on the street it's 1:00 in the
morning it's now what I say to her gym
ball I said all am i go okay it's the
pair base get in a hotel now nothing
good happens right now nothing good
happens on the street nothing
III heard and everybody like like a
[ __ ] collie another thing just man
good happen and then I came back out
that's for Ethiopian guys were there oh
and hey hey you went on the captain they
surrounded me and then Jess around it
guys
fat belly cuz they're not eating hey you
guys our first swim yeah you guys out
for a swim
how's the water is it choppy I slew them
I slew all of them us my friends the
shark and I'm the batter ho down the old
squid honey all squeal I must suck you
boys on I do come on around the squid
guy no no I'm yeah
I pull them underwater I squeeze the
night I squeezed I choke them my
tentacles
suck it no I know that's not on the
squid calm you guys down right quick
with my mouth the old squid old freak
all right forearm a circle
there goes nothing dude was your crowd a
little rowdy on Year's Eve you worried
you do three to one I did you do weren't
they were so great and they've some of
them were older it was really wild I was
like this year crowds definitely older
had a meet-and-greet didn't know there
are a lot of people wait now some an
[ __ ] squid we did we did oh dude knew
so I did two shows at the ice house I
just won't stay local you know so I did
two shows there yeah and for show great
fantastic second show yeah the rowdy
mess though Riley that's Whitney I go
because I had Fahim on the first show
than I had Brian since you know Brian
Simpson he got passed at the store he's
a monster
I'd like to eat at the store monster I
work so I had a son Brian Simpson Derek
and love see myself there is so funny
such a bright killer yeah [ __ ] killer
so I had a pocket yeah so I had him on
the The Late Show Early Show at Fahim
but I was gonna have Whitney come by too
and Whitney goes I don't do New Year's
Eve well she was too rowdy yeah I'm like
no only woody Tom out first Shawn like
it was she time less easy second show
it's just that there's a lot of booze
going around well there are a lot of
fights that broke out in Boston I'm sure
that's bossy in the hotel I'm there next
Saturday yeah in the W so but there's
alcohol there and then you know when
they're doing the count everyone's
waiting for it
so they're distracted they're dropping
the check it was just like it's almost
like I was doing stand-up at a
restaurant because there's like talking
cuz they're ready to go it was just
different yeah it's just different
yeah I'm never comfortable in crowds
especially on times like New Year's Eve
no I've been just have anxiety people
die of all the time I in any any crowds
I have anxiety if I'm same way man I'm
not like my shows I don't but if we go
out after like some restaurant or
somewhere or like I'm at the mall with
my family it's all like it's so out of
character for me to go
so I that's very strange I never but it
was writing the other ends it was
actually part of the hotel yeah I was
like we're here when I when I was in
Philly we you know we had on the show
late when we're walking the guy goes ah
the guy we're uh get back in not over
here I Brennan or Brennan I don't know
but yeah not around here yeah break it
to you Bert get back to your side yep My
Damn gonna watch out for you he'll watch
out for you yeah he was great yep great
man didn't you tell me you were walking
the Norton Arlen's nollans and the cops
were like you guys don't go down that
way you're walking the wrong way oh yeah
yeah
we're walking he goes well honest
doesn't give a [ __ ] about your UFC stuff
then they have something called piece
tallest Oh miss tallest if you go one
block laughs tough yeah Marty girl
Street where the [ __ ] about my dad 78
year old friend one of his oldest
friends I start to tell a story about
the big guy I got I'm wrong deep I got
one guy was like six six and he goes he
in the middle of my story in front of
both our families extended families he
goes what is this about you big guys
with you you're always talking about
muscle guys and yeah thank you
funny dude when I say I was sick during
the holidays I'm telling man like
pneumonia and then Tiger had it my girl
had it and then Boston started getting
sick and then you know no one's sleeping
I was like four days of no sleep in a
row as like oh that's how they torture
people a night when we capture Isis
that's how we tortured me don't I'm
asleep they keep the lights on they play
babies crying well that's what was going
on I'm sleeping on the floor you know it
totally and being sick now at hungry and
cold to that and it brings you to your
knees that house my husband my house
yeah hungry and cold yeah horrible
hungry cold yeah you know when you're
sick you realize just how you're so
fluid but also you're so functional but
also health is priceless it's there's
nothing that guy Rogan who said when
you're sick you want one thing that's
health you want 50,000 things yeah I I
gotta do a better job taking care myself
but I'd have to oh yeah do a better job
well you're pretty yeah you you roll it
deep but I think I can do better yeah
well I feel like you exercise and I eat
like night
exercise every soon they have sleeping
here just lately I haven't because you
know being sick and then on the road I
have like I'm five weeks on week off
five weeks on the road I know that's why
you knows what I do I sleep till I wake
up I can't do because I have my internal
clock that might so I even no matter
what so let's say like for all New
Year's bad example let's say I do a
store The Improv or laugh at time I get
done and say get home at midnight
I'm up 5:30 no matter what 5:00 5:30
a.m. at home usual my body is a lie down
stay and stay stay in bed not open up
this yeah stay in bed and open windows
back to sleeping you will but you got to
go through that initial hour sometimes y
axis that's what I do I don't give I
know you're good at it I wake up and ice
in bed mmm no I'm gonna feel stressed
yep because your heart starts beating
your honor you know it's weird as I got
my little man
Nintendo switch because he played that
target young for Christmas and he loved
it I'm like really you're only even
before like Nintendo switch I'm like
imma get him one so I get on that and I
get him the kiddie games like the Ryan
from YouTube we can stay on the kids I
ran from you qubit Sega take a fake
Mario Kart game and I got him a paw
patrol game they were super kitty I'm
like yeah he's only four oh he'll be
four and fibia
like him nice she gets it he's like and
I'm like oh oh these are too simple and
Kitty for him so I go on so he goes to
bed I'm pissed like spend all this money
on thing it's kid don't [ __ ] like it
so I get on there it connects to the
Internet you can download games alright
haha dude so Papa Bear I'm like you know
what I'm like you know I grew up with
Mortal Kombat yeah so I go out there I'm
like he likes
we're not so every day I walk in the
house we wrestle
soon as I get home we're wrestling
that's just what he'd like to do is
wrestle so soon so I'm like maybe he'll
like a fighting game might be a little
graphic worm and they have more come at
11:00
last time I played was Mortal Kombat 2
20 years ago
yeah dude so I download it and I'm like
yeah let me just set it up for him put
on the easy mode I'm play I'm like holy
[ __ ] I played for for out I learned all
the fatalities and then the next morning
I'm like I'm just gonna try see what he
thinks so we're watching you hey Bubba
you want to try the you know try your
Nintendo again you
pop I'm gonna go oh look there's
actually a new game on there look at
this
I'm show me that give me that and dude
he's [ __ ] and it's it's addictive it's
a well he just he likes that how hard it
is for him to do it which is a good sign
but then it's more combat so that it's
boring its court so like am ia terrible
parent well I'm glad you better know
where my son the son I catch him plans
tonight for 3d and people are getting
shot he's eight they fall down blood
seeps everywhere now I'm like alright I
don't know I but then again I again I go
wait I came all you got to do is draw
this is next thing I know I'm playing I
know next time I'm coach and I'm going
no you got it oh yeah old feet he's
moving it running right I got it you
know and you get crazy ah dude here's
the problem my son can I borrow your
iPad
he's been skiing all day they're
watching Mean Girls I'm like what do you
wanna do if you want to play fortnight
it's good if you build it's like
strategic or the people aren't I guess
in roblox they take these kid hands I'm
like alright you know even you've been
physically active a good first eight
hours again well my son is a crafty
little little so Mitch he's eight nice
little he's craft we certainly can't
[ __ ] well he was he doesn't know how
to do that but on YouTube he was putting
insects se X in different forms then he
put in cantaloupes cuz he thought that's
what it's cantaloupes he heard somebody
say cantaloupes got some can hold is he
he's eight yeah and his search history
is I was like hey bro it was all his
chicks like suckin their tits and huge
tits I'm like yeah I didn't go come here
I go
it's going on but say your old man likes
Calloway no I go if you're gonna use my
iPad you can play those games don't be
going on YouTube and looking up sexy
guys why not very good question I
understand you're a boy I get it all
adult young right now
I gotta help you through that stuff
that's all I said he goes whatever if
you should really Papa likes cantaloupe
ah so you're not gonna stop at he's a no
he's interested in yeah I didn't want to
shame him
no you can't cuz then it's like sex not
like bad [ __ ] now any won't dawn do you
know how embarrassing do you know what I
watched I watched the Kevin Hart
documentary oh really
have you seen it no it's good I like his
fan [ __ ] guy because I people some
comics I don't watch that thing it's him
like boasting about himself all this I'm
like really
and then jtech swingers have you watched
Kevin Hart documentary on Netflix oh
you'll know he goes I work on computers
and I'm inspired watch it he was one of
the best doctors ever seen it's a five
part series do so obviously its it's his
thing you know it's called don't [ __ ]
this up the stuff that he left in that
makes him look bad
you just can't help but love the guy I
love him I told you that yeah I know
he's one of my so they leave in you know
the Himba cheating on his wife yeah they
show his like hit when he finds out you
know was one of his best friends who did
it he talks about that they have a scene
on there cuz he has his like red paper
cut boys were the [ __ ] they call his
crew they came up with oh great and
they're all great his crews great yeah
and they're all doing their own thing
right but he has his trainer who's with
him all the time was his boy and they're
super close he's part of the red cup
boys or whatever it is and he you know
once he finds out one of his friends is
the one who tried to extort money from
and film the sex tape and bleak tit to
his wife once he found that out he had
this like horrible resentment in him and
he's like it's gonna come out one way or
the other and just came out and I was
gonna add it but I said not to let you
guys see it so him and his boys are
doing a short film for some giant arena
and they're flying back on his private
jet and they're drinking and they're
gambling and chemicals so I decided to
leave it in so you guys can see how it
is dude I was like I can't believe he
left this in because he was drinking and
something's you know he has this inside
him it's gonna get out and his his buddy
who's his trainer his closest friend he
starts arguing so you're telling me you
would have made money from work for me
Anna strain of successfully met Kevin
he's like are you [ __ ] me oh yeah he
goes you own a home [ __ ]
and he's belittling he's like you don't
make money you won't be [ __ ] without me
this trainers huge they are literally
about to fight they've got these boys
get between them the stewardess on
playing called the cops so they'll and
the cops are there so Kevin the next day
is like a you know I had this horrible
issue it was coming one well you know
nothing but love and so the next day
they're all good but the stuff he left
in his house all right his dad is his
dad in there they have the AUSA that
went you were supposed to host the
Oscars I got choked there's a strain of
shout to his trainer I got choked up cuz
they in doing shows in Australia and
they show him when he gets the call to
host the Oscars and he doesn't get that
emotion on the show eats emotionally
like his his buddy gets married but when
he gets a call from the Oscars I got
choked then I get him on the podcast
okay cuz cuz cuz he called me because he
owes okay it sounds you know I really
appreciate the opportunity hangs up in
the chemical areas and name he goes
would he say goes Chris Rock Bill Cosby
goes through their names I hosted the
Oscars and Kevin Hart and he starts
talking his mom who passed away he's
like this is for you I know you're
watching I was getting emotional he's
like this the biggest step in my career
and he's like emotional he's like I
can't wait and then it shows these
[ __ ] bloggers bringing up his old
tweets [ __ ] and they and they film and
they they cover everything where he's a
part like his he said sorry fifty
thousand times but he even he admits he
made a mistake because his publicist
goes Kevin you're not dealing with this
right you have to acknowledge because he
said his this thing is if my son was gay
I'd whup his ass I'd do this he didn't
acknowledge the violence part you said
oh I apologize That's not me but he
didn't actually own it and come out with
it yeah but it shows before he did the
video or anything his big publishers and
steams like Kevin this is the this what
we're gonna have to do to make sure you
all give the Oscars and all that and
he's not listening to him and posts a
video from his bed and his boys who are
comics are clown like this my [ __ ]
Dini out of bed he goes he has three
chains on like he's [ __ ] easy
his eyes are barely open he's just like
hey listen he's he's just firing off
what he wants to do remember his
publicist like I'm telling you man
you're [ __ ] up your [ __ ] so you
can see all these companies stop [ __ ]
with them oh and his friends like he was
doing that
movie with those same uh the guy from
Breaking Bad that movie
he's like Bryan Cranston's out as far as
doing PR with you because he's on
Broadway it's a big lbgtq community up
there and Kevin I thought oh I get it
and she goes we do we need to issue an
apology us time to watch Ellen I've
already done on there she goes Kevin
that's like in a work man if you're
gonna do this you have to acknowledge it
he's like nah [ __ ] that I'm not doing
this and then it shows now right that
was like a year ago shows him now he's a
guy [ __ ] up he's a guy he's like
there's a lot of times I'm right because
I was so wrong on that here's I got in
my head and I I'm with you remember I
came out with like [ __ ] these people I'm
with Kevin he's right he's apologize but
you watch it Kevin even like yeah I
didn't own it I was just like now it's
old [ __ ] and that's why I thought I
thought I was doing the right thing
about it on it yeah he's he's I'm tired
of documentaries so by the way I'm just
really quick the man when I said that
Bill Cosby had about 20 specials he does
remember how he looked it up and it was
only one Bill Cosby
yeah you're right well I thought we
looked it up no and now I could find one
album no we found like he's done over 23
oh there's like one hour Nara but we
were looking good how many spider yes
how many one hours years ago no this is
about a couple months ago and I was like
oh he's done 25 or something and we
could only find one for whatever reason
and I looked it up on Rogan robo's like
Jamie was like they're 23 some crazy
number of hours like crazy like I'm
saying like Bill Cosby as [ __ ] up as
he is we were talking about what what he
was as a comic who meet you and I were
we were all talking I don't know where
you go just cuz you mentioned Bill Cosby
with the Oscars oh yeah comics but he
was so it's so tragic doing that would
see Kevin was such a big deal for me
like oh I want to see this documentary
man but you you so you can't help but
love [ __ ] for that to rise getting [ __ ]
for the I think so it just dumbasses
online and I kill this dog's [ __ ] or
gate or comics but where he wins he's
ecology he wins every time but he did
what's funny is like you see how good he
takes care of the people around him damn
how grateful he is and how telling you
and how he gives to his all with my own
eyes and no one else did this he did
this on the DL this girl wasn't even as
they she was this
this little gal who was running back and
forth and she was probably like 40 and
she was it was so hard for her she was
trying to all this stuff and she some
guy was like spilled some thing and he
just I could I watched some clock and
he's just watch clock reached him pulls
out like three four hundred dollars and
he just goes look he goes you're doing a
great job tonight thank you I did it
really quietly just to add just to help
that personality it's funny just his dad
died kidding right his dad was absent
father absentee father he just wasn't
around could cocaine name it he's he
wasn't around
his dad's around now right and he has
some condition where he needs like all
this medical device and Kevin's bring
around the family in the and you know
the dad's not doing well he's like hey
Kevin so he takes him aside and again I
can't leave Kevin left stuff in he's in
and they're like in this like sweet nor
in New York something he's like hey keV
you know I need disease and he goes dad
stop I don't need to run around I don't
need the whole sad story what do you
need
he's a but brother I need I need about
seven granules I was gonna give you
twenty so just just come to me and tell
me how much you don't give me the
runaround yeah I'm gonna give you twenty
days or so that's more than enough
because alright go on
I love it be like [ __ ] I love it my kind
of money just to hear you give me money
man I gotta come to you and ask you with
my top [ __ ] is gonna [ __ ] dude how much
you gotta watch it man
listen I I got some stuff going yeah
what do you got going on there oh you
know what reminds me what we didn't know
what we fishery did it online but I
Thalia Thalia guessed it away by a
landslide yeah a lot of people like why
was it co on there he was on the show
this year yeah he came on there but and
also Thiel asked us to take him off the
voting just so the fans know we didn't
take him off I was the only monitor just
so he could defend his but like he was
not he well he was like God will I was
in ominous you know man you and I do
King this thing so it's we're different
yeah so he's like he was ironic he goes
I want to step away and just you know
I'm not gonna offend the battle and step
off yeah give it somebody the
opportunity how's it go I had you on
there just cuz you the defending
champions nothing to take me off yeah
cuz if he wanted to you know turn it up
you know you made a video or some [ __ ]
or come on but Julia's performance to
the best out of all the years is the
best I've ever seen
he's so great thought that that
Instagram I post did you see that 14,000
you see it go to my Instagram for a sec
the the video we posted was cool
yeah right there right there watch out
noxious this is just play this this one
yeah
hey bud sup brah
how was your New Year's Eve show at the
whoo at the Wilbur I heard you sold it
out there last minute inching up to the
laughs inching up to Showtime right
inching up to Showtime he sold the last
ticket
what's that hold I think 1100 yeah
was it 49ers he was in Chicago yeah
what's the hold that holds do you know
what I don't remember I remember now
3550 seats yeah hey Philip please
I did too two on New Year's Eve that's
just mine
and I did two before that four that's
14th like look at him the most possible
face and a he's just lying there all I
know at the end of his night
he's a funny scare in the world that's
so [ __ ] funny I was the best when we
left the voting up you know and I it
wasn't closed beeps I mean it wasn't
starting my landslide close I knew it
Chris's brother will tell you that since
he was a kid he lives to do one thing
that's make people laugh that's what he
likes to do he's the best yeah he goes I
go he goes well what'd I do wrong what
what
did you just get you so you flew to
Wilbur on Saturday or Friday I flew to
new
I flew in New York um that on the 30th
and I took a train up to Boston on the
31st I went to see play in New York
called halfway [ __ ] go to heaven she
family that I was with I did see my
family but they remember they were in
Utah oh yes well I flew to New York I
went saw half way [ __ ] go to heaven
my boy John Ortiz great actor in his own
right and a sick director um I was I was
a challenge on Jimmy Burke I was crying
I was crying through that play it takes
place in a women's shelter I cried 25
times and if some of the best actors
I've ever seen in my life oh dude I know
John Wallace Oxenberg that's John right
there John yeah phenomenal actor and an
amazing did a sick job he wrote it he
directed it that [ __ ] right
there who writes that [ __ ] right
there is a Pulitzer prize-winning
playwright and a genius but that's not
John or two you know that's a guy who
wrote it and oh my god just yeah but
John Ortiz is in the player no um no
John just directed Abbot John John so
John started the labyrinth Theatre
Company with a guy named Philip Seymour
Hoffman they were best friends
Philip Seymour Hoffman and John Ortiz
well and I mean you know he's I've seen
some great stuff from there but he's
amazing amazing actor such a great guy I
see John damn there every day boxing
right oh yeah all of that my neighbor
I'm so proud of a man it was such a
beautiful play some people can write
some people can act and write and you
don't know who the [ __ ] they are and I
put him up against anybody he's just
like he was just like how are you this
good oh that [ __ ] playwright my god
what else did you do out there uh I saw
the great dub David often the great
Jimmy Burke and we acted like silly
geese that's what I did
and then I went and did the Wilbur okay
I didn't do much as long as I'm with my
friends I'm eating good food drinking
good wine and seeing theater and now I
get to stand up everything else is
getting working better there's nothing
more there's nothing better that's what
that's what Chris Rock said or not Chris
Rock Kevin Hart when he get wet during
that dock he goes I missed this I miss
New Yorkers I missed the comedy scene
because you know you're not really in
clubs he's so big happen clubs so he's
at the cellar
he's like sit around the table with
Chris Rock and his buddies just a bit
salad they're sipping whiskey and he's
like this is what I meant yes this yes
yeah cuz you know you're all that's what
we went to the cellar to I always go to
the cellar because I just love that
upstairs that the olive tree I'll be in
Nashville this weekend huh hi there in
January 10th January 10th 11th oh that's
nice yes I know next weekend I'm at the
Foxwoods Connecticut and I Drive to
Boston for the you're gonna love it
I've been Wilbur twice oh it's great
love the Wilbur Wilbur Nashville weird
name January 10 11 is a nice name okay
calm great spot yep little Nashville
chicken foot then I got Cleveland
January 30th there it is yeah January 30
31 first is yet three weeks two weeks
off yeah voice five weeks in a row here
that's a lot you know I mean often
another five being a road dogs hey get
good dude we're doing the right thing
how much you love it though don't you
love it love it
nothing better there just isn't it's
fantastic
I'll never stop oh yeah why would you
dude thanks gonna rinks here's the thing
bro I'm an intense dude you're intense
to me you're a type-a personality you
try and get after it that's what we hear
in this culture always get after it Oh
excuses when you hit the wall climb the
wall all that [ __ ] what what about
what about recharging dude about do what
about hold on what makes people great
the most successfully we know they're
strong not in the way room but minded is
mentally dude man I'm some of your metal
guys you had a calm your mind dude
mental fine don't talk about calm how
about palm the number one app for sleep
and meditation and they've even teamed
up with the old great one the goat for
some LeBron James
that's right LeBron ran your own calm
know that your mind is like any other
muscle in your body and you can calm can
help you train your brain so you sleep
better you have less stress and you
perform a teaser of calm for many many a
year now or
and there's nothing as I get older
there's nothing like I stay sleeps most
important thing meditation and it's a
really good app for meditation who
doesn't even want to be like LeBron
except for gonna have his hairline all
you got to do is go to calm calm slash
fight or you get 40% off the column
premium member [ __ ] it's really good
it's a really good step by step project
not only gets you to sleep so I'll tell
you stories look at these great light
helps you rest they got these people
these amazing voices right I do the
British voice there's a French dude - I
think night the French is discussed I
know the English the French guys like
this oh go to sleep
oh go to sleep
I'm never gonna sleep now I know you
need the British home yes of course yeah
does he speak this way yeah by the way
there are always always different people
who can speak and speak to you the way
you should be spoken to and it's time to
call my mind and you know German one
well it starts but that's not how to do
it that's a good way to wake up if you
must wake up my friend you have to wake
up all that's the matter yes but listen
LeBron loves it you got rain you can
hear leaves your sleep stories
meditations it really is great for a
limited time listeners can join the
broad and using calm the 40% discount
for an annual membership of com.com
slash fighter unlock content to help you
focus ease stress sleep better I've done
it it's amazing I've done it too also
calm calm / fighter also I love this
note LeBron loves the rain in the leaves
oh yeah calm calm calm / fighter you
want straight teeth like me whoa you
want straight teeth like other people on
a you want straight teeth like Brad nerd
no it's got very straight you want
straight teeth likes right huh nope
yeah Chad has great teeth braces got as
a kid yeah I know it's you had to do
brace I can always tell he's a brace
face those days with new technology you
can do candid which are clear aligners
ok so you came and really see what's
going on Brian you should get the metal
ones nope you'd be quiet'
candid they deliver clear aligners
directly to you and straighten your
teeth for 65% less than braces yeah but
after the doctor's office like sit
around them don't feel like it done now
you don't they're comfortable they're
removable they're totally about without
anyone noticing a thing you never have
to set foot in the doctor's office
Brennan or waiting room your treatment
is prescribed remotely by a licensed
orthodontist and Canada livers
everything you need right to your door
but does it take six years to get these
negative straight guys it'll take six
months sometimes only works with
orthodontist never general dentists that
means your treatment will be designed by
an expert in tooth with 20 years of
experience on average can it move my
teeth hey I'm ready to take the first
step towards a straight teeth the
average treatment length is just six
months half years I are seeing results
one hour then learn more about Canada's
process I'm gonna coupler a 3d scan of
your teeth mmm candid studio near you
and is the simplest freest way to get
started so $75 off by using the code
fighter at candid code calm slash
fighter
that's candid code calm slash fighter
use the code fight over $75 off what are
straight teeth worth to you I know can
decode concise fighter code finder you
want to totally optimize your body day
and night you go to on it calms you can
they straight my teeth bro
they can't that's the one thing they
can't do if they'll straighten your
brain out with alpha brain alpha brain
instant you can they straight now your
mood what about my joy your mood
melatonin spritz what ammo they got
joint stuff they got they got they got
essential nutrients for your joints
strong bones they got key minerals
spirulina and chlorella vitamin d3 spray
food dude what if my new year's
resolution was getting shaped do they
have like cool workouts are the on at
six you've got basically honest six body
weight on at six kettlebell on at six
steel mace you got streaming fitness
classes you got all kinds of things you
can get your own home gym with stuff
that will last you forever primal
kettlebell something hit on those
kettlebell sets mmm you got you got
sandbags so you feel it's like to really
wrestle a human being dead body you know
what I mean eyes you got to carry your
your comrade to save me that's right you
know I'm saying you got battle ropes
suspension rings I work the rings that's
why my back is so crazy wide now you
should work my ring I'm I'm not working
here bugging ring unless it's on it do
you have on
- around your little starfish because if
you do we're coming over and I'll work
it ring I'll clean your whistle oh all
right now listen our comms last [ __ ] set
up that's better
ten percent off yeah okay how was your
guys holidays yeah good I went home to
San Jose and then I came back hung out
with my sister she came to visit Hugh
she's very cute yeah we ended up
stopping by a bar in Santa Monica hung
out with chin and some of the mouth guys
Daniel was trying to hit on her the
entire time she's but yeah had fun
shout out to Corey for taking care of us
that night that's cool yeah man there
you - you the two of you caused some
problems
- you cost them because your sister
single - yes well yeah yeah
congratulations
that's nice yeah oh yeah in San Jose in
two weeks
mm-hmm are there fight I'm gonna stop on
my no not this Saturday
no come on up mm-hmm tell the system on
our she's back back in school already
oh cool Ohio Ohio I got sucked in that
Ohio State Clemson game I'm not a
college football guy hmm I can see what
college football be very exciting
they're kids they make mistakes
last-minute sorry back to your sisters
so Columbus into the month come on now
they're friends ah let's do it yeah what
do you mean just coming up - no it goes
well Ohio State Ohio State Clemson game
I like knowing about football all right
oh okay so this was submitted by Anthony
Diaz and just a little update with the
college scandal so Lori
Allen is pretty sure that she's gonna
spend some time in prison and she's
taking it upon herself to hire a prison
coach is the teachers lingo and your
horse it you generally get hard that's
exactly what you do that though because
then it makes the news and then it
sounds like you're getting but also
you're not gonna you're not gonna do
hard time you yeah but the one thing you
should know about prisons there's way
more fights and violence and female
prisons in males you know that did not
yes Wow I'm a big fan of 60 days in is
that true yeah yeah and they divide
women and the men and every time they go
now for you women and they give them
training and they're because in the
women there's way more fights there's
way more there's way more drama there's
a lot of fights way more in female
prisons way more Wow there's no
structure like the guys have structured
yeah there's this gay guys race can
shake your [ __ ] dick off but the
women that just they fight I'm fighting
these people on 60 days in white the
[ __ ] are they doing this one so they go
through when guys like gamma corrections
officer I'd like to know what it's like
on the other side new season started
last night shot to a knee so he's all
you know I'm a correctional officer I
want to feel like what's up like on the
side so what didn't they get this one
they got another guy he's like you know
I'm african-american I played football
and I've always been tough on a see how
tough I am see if I make it through jail
then they get this one yes I was a
marine for a while but I'm just a big
fan I'm gonna see what it's like he gets
in there and he you know I haven't seen
past this first episode and soon he gets
in you tell you why it's out he's a girl
[ __ ] what did I do [ __ ] this here's the
thing that you can go to jail so they go
undercover for 60 days to help the
prison or jail learn like what like they
get the inside look like what they're
doing wrong how they could do better
so there's therefore 60 days as an
inmate they have cover stories it's 60
days dude in [ __ ] a real time legit
jail they had one guy in who he went
when he was younger and he was in a gang
they put him in there
that [ __ ] started running things
and they would take him out for
interviews like what are you doing like
I went back to my ways man just do it 60
out of 100
in this [ __ ] and they like the lingo he
just took [ __ ] over yeah I had a friend
who went to jail a real tough guy and
same thing with him he just naturally
kind of took over yeah but in season I
don't you said to me because I had a
really good time I don't I don't get why
they do it though there's no money you
don't get paid I'm the experience I
don't know if stupid I thought maybe was
like you know at least she makes some
money years I don't know 100 grand
survival just wouldn't be fun
it looks so terrible the sleeping
arrangements just that's terrible
that's your cot enjoy that [ __ ] behind
the contraband there [ __ ] it's crazy
good show them quality show quality show
quality show great show there's a new
show though that I'm really into called
thousand-pound sisters it's the best
show on TV thousand-pound sisters and
they are such characters so here's the
problem the thousand-pound sister that's
them there oh they're so one the left
basically $700,000 [ __ ] look at her
forehead zoom in on her forehead
this one this [ __ ] is so fat the fat
started growing out of her head that's
it great so she the sister right goes
did you know they're from the south so
she goes yeah we we thought maybe a tomb
or something like that we took your many
doctors turns out she has so much fat
just came to start shooting through her
forehead I've never seen him like this
oh it's but they're characters they're
funny as [ __ ] what is she holding there
that's a scene she making lasagna that's
beef and then she goes she goes hey
should I put bacon in the lasagnas girl
you fat she is that would be pretty
tasty though and then they put lasagna
in it it's fantastic oh hey and then
they can't get a scale putting it away
on cuz they're so heavy they can't get a
scale so they go to a junkyard what's
going on here
that's hard to watch that's just the fat
[ __ ] what's going on but they these
sisters go to her that's just another
fat one now those aren't the sisters but
they go to a junkyard to weigh in and
the first one weighs in and she's like I
don't know she's like they go to a
junkyard
they can't go rent there's no regular
scales kid don't go up that high
so the one goes I think she's like or 70
the other one gets on this she's like
six seventy or something like that they
start crying they do but that so they're
trying to I can't surgery yeah bye-bye
plastic surgery or something
so this is a Grecian gasai condition
feel so bad actually
look at that oh but they they have a
pretty good size youtube channel I bet
they do
that's I'm so again their friend their
fan share saying on there they go you
know we have like 100k subscribers she
goes and we're gonna now start like how
terrible they go we're gonna announce to
our fans that word lose it we're gonna
lose weight and get the surgery and the
fans were not happy well the fans are
you're not gonna live no well she knows
that she was out you know I'm a diet I
want to live she I don't know what
happens episode the it debuted last week
the one on the heavy one on the left
with the fat face the fat forehead
dude she starts [ __ ] to because I
told my girl we're watching she goes who
would be into this a oh excuse me
no there's the chubbiest of chasers out
there and I went I bet you there's some
black dude out there who is obsessed
with that big fat one sho'nuff she is
alright guys she's crying about it man
Cheers I got a man we haven't met boom
some black dude like what's up it's just
that's how it goes then yeah so we'll
see we'll see if it works out they get
married that's incredible
that is simply incredible you know some
people are into very I've watched my
500-pound life or whatever but the
thousand pound sisters now do they all
unfortunately they don't they don't live
long today I mean that's a certain
listen even with the surgery the success
rates not good it's like less than like
5% this is the best part they're talking
to the doctor who's doing the surgery
like the doctor yes and they're both
sipping big gulps and doctor they're
trying to talk serious doctor and you
see that the Raj is a young guy he's
just annoying us Han stop saying because
they're drinking the the soda while
they're talking is that's a huge big off
you're drinking how much so did I was
so did you guys drink a day and the
small one goes [ __ ] how many Saudis do I
drink she tells him Saudis so I call
every drink Saudis now she has [ __ ] how
many Saudis let's see I finished a
12-pack and put 18 a day and she goes
their diet though docked and she goes
like this in the doctor's excuse me she
goes their diet so what we were told
well we were told is we drink the diet
we can eat sugar cuz it cancel it out
and the doctor goes that's what they
told you how she is that's what they
told me he goes and how's that working
out for you too
and she goes [ __ ] weird like -
they both start laughing
they're funny man funny
the Oh [ __ ] weird like dude she
hits the other fat one I get both sorry
what is this on where do you even find
these channel I know he's Channel I
don't know man it's so funny though and
then they get workout equipment and they
give them the ThighMaster but their guts
hangover so they can't put in their legs
no try to figure out how to do you're a
prisoner each side they're all do it's
miserable the how their ankles hold up I
have no idea leave the crop top anyways
further workout equipment they get this
you know those shake weights and she's
all and her sister goes damn that looks
nasty
she does do you feel as though she has a
little bit I keep doing it she's get
away from your face stuff oh my god it's
so funny but the reason why it works cuz
they're funny yeah I bet poor things
yeah their mom really [ __ ] them she
like made fun of them all time with
their kids there's this sometimes it's
that crazy sex abuse it goes on too and
31 32 31 and 32 Lord the one can't walk
now Hospice
oh go to go to five fast fact what's
going on there you see it no right where
you were out that's the same way I do my
facts you need to know give me the five
one Tammy and Amy are YouTube stars in
their fans reach out this let me see
they say reach out to TLC to help them
watch this real quick yeah for a second
they're sweet I'm doing a review okay
all right I've seen enough that's good
once you know I'll do a head butt
contest look keep going now Amy is
married oh yeah she has a husband
trailer green hair
her husband's funny - he's like [ __ ]
imma lose weight next year - their niche
shut up keep going amazing ten we tried
to kill herself last year that's the
bigger one yeah there's something
obviously well she hasn't left the house
in seven years yes she lets us the house
in seven years yeah it's a sure she
leaves can be JLo be huge turtle the
biggest hurdle oh so they tell their mom
so the first time she ever leaves the
house in seven years they meet with the
mom and then I go we're gonna have
bypass Drake stomach surgery to lose
weight moms like yanking at stake with
that [ __ ] you're gonna do [ __ ] yeah yeah
the mom's an [ __ ] yeah also the mom
ain't skinny no keep going does a five
right there Wow the chip five amazing
yeah mom seems like a real [ __ ] peach
there's some weird [ __ ] going on there
childhood abuse and it's horrible I'll
tell you this these these TLC six of my
600 life when they show me eating I'm
like I'm hungry
they show the foods they like yeah you
might get a house yeah a date with a
crazy the best is one of the other
doctor and they haven't lost weight and
they're like I don't know I've stuck to
your diet 1,500 calories a day and the
doctors like no no [ __ ] you're
lying
yeah you've put on 30 pounds there's
only one way to do that father it'll
make a lot of food makes a lot of people
my father is a man who never lies yet if
you talk to him I was like so God I
understood you ate look at that forehead
what happened there it's fat that just
stopped my she's so fat it it just it
just fills into there no there's nowhere
else to go all right okay so my dad I go
it's crazy
he ate my ice cream yesterday and
lemon meringue pie huh cool and had some
whiskey and he goes no I didn't yeah you
did and you also had how many bananas
and he goes I don't know - I go you're
lying to me you are you had an entire
bushel of bananas he had a whole bushel
I go so that's what you did it was
Sunday night I get so much no matter if
I go food makes you a liar you're lying
- yeah yes I'm not in a court of law I
don't know what this conversation that's
just fascinating though oh yeah tell you
and see how help let me episodes
thousand-pound sisters what's the next
that's great you gotta watch it yet okay
so oh that's so a couple days ago this
came out that this woman she is a 43
year old single mother who was going to
Georgia State University but had to drop
out because she couldn't pay a $700
outstanding balance she also is a
hairdresser when she isn't driving for
uber one day she went and picked up a
passenger they got to talking and she
told him about how every time she gets
around to having the 700 dollars to pay
off her school debt something would
happen with her kids where they would
need that money and so she eventually
got kicked out of school and a couple
days later the university called her
saying that somebody paid it off for her
she found out that it was her
uber passenger and so she was able to
register for her classes she just
graduated with her associates and he
actually went to her graduation to see
her yeah that's cool [ __ ] dude that's
so cool ah and now she's going back to
get her BA this lets them together
I love cool feel good it's a good story
can i brag for a second about something
that happened to me I think it's worth
it I I'm 50 - yes I was on my flight
yeah
I'm not gonna give the airline or
anything else I'm on my flight I asked
the lovely flight attendant something
about if I could buy some food she goes
yeah cuz I had fallen asleep and then I
went back to sleep and so I basically
was in my I was I don't know you know I
felt like I looked like [ __ ] on JetBlue
it doesn't matter and I'm like this if
I'm singing like that and as I get off
the F the plane this 20
something-year-old flight attendant goes
thank you this is for you and gives me a
napkin with her name and number oh yeah
and I was like yes I got it
[ __ ] she's got it yes right [ __ ]
there got it
oh yeah to go you know that night I did
not go here at night and in northern I
dream but I will admit that I feels I
sent a text saying thank you I'm
flattered
not available I did hey no I just wings
I didn't want her to feel like I didn't
want her to be embarrassed and then she
was beautiful too great but about as she
said this is the year I don't want to
sleep on anything and I was like well
that's awesome
Wow but I was like I said this made my
day I'm sorry
come on man I mean I was like ice the
kids still got it hey hold on and I
thought was sleeping the whole time
shitty shitty you've let me have swin
you know you got the win dude right all
right now what are you gonna do but
why'd you say you're unavailable well
because I just am you know I'm in spam
that was that that situation is just
what it is you know I don't know I just
I was yeah
but ruin her year no I mean I I said
thank you and you're awesome but I just
you know not even a dick pic no to start
the year off and all fresh I'm gonna
ruin it that way I was sleeping I guess
I look sexy look at me hold on phoner
I'll look at my eyelashes do you drool -
a little bit like you see with your
mouth open it like this oh hey this is a
white girl white girl oh yeah that's a
good question
I'm not gonna mention it ah white girl
not a white girl
Asian not even that oh but I'm very
proud of my since a black girl I'm not
saying anything no I just want to fill
this out what do you think I'm gonna
fake you think I'm gonna find this poor
girl no I just don't wanna I don't wanna
out her somehow but I'm not right no no
yes in fact she was a she was a hey was
it a man sister was it a man you son of
a [ __ ] was it no justice flattered I
would have been just as flattered but it
was just like I was just like the well
I'm sleeping on a plane is the Thunder
so cute when I sleep it was a sister and
he told her no no I'm not saying the
race of the person but they were not
white I'll tell you all the details on
camera dude
you think we're gonna figure it out I
light it then throw but I was just so
flattered and she was good looking I was
that either still think it's a man it's
a dude I'm not but the point is it was
the Don desirable while you're still
even working all right
think you got your hair up just does
that mean I don't know ha you're a cutie
now think if you got your shitty year
what do I do what would I do with my
hair bro I don't know dude I'm on TV
nights is working on it I know hey come
on come on cloning hey CAD my sister
she's going to see her her daughter
broke her nose so she went to this Bob
this guy was on how'd she break your
nose she was in school have fell and hit
her knee her knee hit her own especially
when you know you break your nose yeah
be a real Sochi where my sister went to
a plastic surgeon like an expensive wig
I reset it it's all good she cuz sister
[ __ ] her daughter's beautiful sis he has
money she's got money she was like if
this is where I'm gonna spend money yeah
I said you tell ask that [ __ ] guy
about lid surgery
I want my lids done on your I want the
best guy to Douma lids and I'm gonna be
I can't even cuter do you not gonna even
know I'm gonna come in until somebody
notices right what's your hair done your
lids sky's the limit a tease do with the
hair done okay there's a limit to what I
can do with my hair well if there's some
doctor out there like oh I can do here I
can do lids
you'll I can do next and then it's like
waiting shoes
what are you talking about with next
reefer one careful
my neck is tight I don't know chicken
skin on my neck what do you we're just
spitballing ideas no man me for one dude
what do you let's hear now my neck
doesn't look cold
then why are you shaking but saying yes
at the same time cuz your now is the
diagonals your neck looks like Willie
Nelson I'm a cutie dude I still got
that's not still got a dude and fight
off that's so cool that little twin Doug
young playing hey man don't twinks don't
dig me anymore so II didn't you know
you're getting older as a man is 1k men
stop looking at you and I'm and I used
to walk around I was the hottest thing I
was like I'm so hot dude I went I went
to the mall earlier today and to get to
the G the men's jeans I go through the
the makeup and perfume and a lot of
twinks working at north North's or
Bloomingdale's dude it is murderers row
man you get your dick suck you fall down
it's like a [ __ ] oh yeah it's just a
value and they like yeah man
oh yeah you get like I'm Little Red
Riding Hood
you get dry-humped with their eyes on I
feel so uncomfortable
they love you eyes on you huh just a big
man
thing if I was gay
well what else we got who was it friend
of mine uh knows you community well
bring that skinny legs though skinny I
go what I hope legs are not okay he just
wears really tight jeans ago but that's
right but to get the squads out Pelt on
every day done it twice twice since the
you you can workout but you don't put on
you don't probably more sighs now right
I don't want I try no but I don't do
anything I know that you could if you
really I mean oh good yeah we have to
eat a lot and lift different yeah you
lift it's the only thing I'll do heavy
now is deadlift and bench dumbbell but
still do that heavy oh yeah
what are you used for the dumbbells 100
it's nice to set the ten with those the
dumbbell and that would then I do the
and I do policy I do deadlift wat and
then I do peloton twice a day but when
you were oh you know I do I do uh a dip
a dip everyday dips are good huh oh no
no the tobacco
oh those dips are cool too hard on your
joints but I did
tobacco less nicotine time when you were
training fighting wiser you hardly
weights did you are you trained what
when you were trained for in UFC
top-heavy you de big time oh you did big
Papa love heavy so you were doing all
Olympic [ __ ] once a week out your head
oh really horn land don't say but you've
been lifting weights heavy since fourth
grade sort of right yes that stunt your
growth you might be the only right Yuki
not true and I bet that's a message oh
yeah
it might make you grow bigger as a
pre-2006 great Wow
grape creatine and I would [ __ ] my pants
no just doing it to look like ed
McCaffrey and so you just you were just
lifting all the times obsessed with it
amazing it
I think this never that's why you never
got injured actually you're the only
athlete I know did it for 30 years who's
actually doesn't have you don't have any
issues did you ever even have any
operation nope
Wow nothing that's a big deal after for
my hips Hill tykes I read the bike so
much I wonder if I get a regular bike
like a road bike yeah but if you'd
imagine if I can spin if you were to if
you I think if you keep lifting your
whole life that's the probably best way
to stay injury-free alright soon yeah
yeah not go too heavy
alright but even your neck you're do you
still have that problem with your neck
are you good yeah I'm a nice little
tight yeah it's not you know well I
brought head and neck issue then on the
plane I went I was on the train to
Boston and I went I was like mother no
took some CBD oil put that on my neck it
works shoved pure spectrum yeah and then
I and then I had to kind of leave that
did it right it did it [ __ ] did it
now Papa likes to wake up in the morning
is that the kid goes to school I popped
that nicotine patch you know and I got
that peloton right hi Papa nicotine it's
you mean pretty I dip a little high oh
yeah I'll get you buck I'll you little
buzz in the morning I'd sip it with
coffee are you [ __ ] your pants I've had
to jump off that belt on a few times
Hamish the workout here's the thing
about peloton can't pause it so I'm
missing some of the reps but yeah I
started doing nicotine kiss good for
your brain how about my dad hi roasting
me my own father I'm telling a long
story with a bunch of people and I'm
just adding stuff in there and
everyone's like laughing my father goes
now how much that story do you guys
think it's true oh oh dude I didn't tape
Oklahoma attacks you so I'm gonna do
this giant you got I'm on this casino
sort so what like you it's a big deal to
get on the casino tour like it's a big
guild so you know you gotta sell tickets
right - guns casino tour so I've done
Borgata which is huge and hard rock
which is huge it's gone great so I'm in
Oklahoma on Saturday I did brick town on
Friday
Oklahoma City drove to Tulsa Oklahoma
brain [ __ ] crazy rain so I'm there
for you know a Hard Rock Hotel Tulsa and
[ __ ] an hour before the show a
tornado warning it's right near there
I'm like I'm in my hotel like the [ __ ]
is that
the magic America's Papa laughs cancel
the show mango what'd you hear that
tornado we don't get those in December
especially this close it ain't good
everybody's leaving it's a ghost down
there in the casino yo what I got to do
the show man here's that let's see we're
right in half an hour like ah dude I'm
like because there's a line he goes yeah
a lot of people he texts me I said I
went dude I'm doing this giant casino
it's 15 minutes for the show there's
eight people in there it seats like 1600
there's no speaking there sellout huge
and I tell the guy yo I can't go out
there do I go those eight people tell me
to come the green room I'll do a show
for her act ain't doing it out there
they're not gonna in the stage like
they've had like
[ __ ] kiss there they've had like
these huge because the stage is so big
yes I'm like just have them come onstage
I'll perform but don't leave in the
crowd now and I go listen dude is there
any way we can start half an hour later
you just can't do it because the Native
American rules we have to keep time it's
different like I'm sure you can start
Leonard of the clubs we're on Native
American land here we can't start any
later I go dude there's eight people out
there bro here's I don't know tell you
man do you want a campsite no we can't
cancel let's give another 15 minutes see
you guys okay well I can maybe push the
8:05
at 7:55 people came in she Asus because
they didn't know once they found out it
was gone nah dude can't I show it dude
yeah I wanna dump my kids city I got
snowed in tornadoes a whole different
thing snow just can't I was so sure I
was I was scared I'm like oh I want to
leave I don't I don't want to die in a
hard rocking new snow and if that
[ __ ] tornado hits at Hard Rock I'm
gonna stop Lawrence here gonna let no
it's terrible no everyone's scared man
it was cool though great show that's you
say good couch was like him when light
when Buffalo two years ago there's a
like a blizzard I go oh I call just I'm
like oh dude I'm in Buffalo there's a
blizzard man why the [ __ ] would you send
me out here in December cancel this
shows use damn Buffalo dude so he was
let me talk to club owner I guess it's
Buffalo what we do dude people came to
the sold-out shows [ __ ] give me
snowmobiles they come two more people
come they party yeah yeah it's fantastic
O'Brien buffs in New York and I was
driving in there was a snow blizzard up
in the mountains and it's been a long
time since I've driven in snow spaceman
O'Brien was slip-sliding all over the
[ __ ] yeah I said pushing her a little
bit I was going to be late they just
made my plane four minutes
how about was driving Derek and a son
from Oklahoma City to Tulsa right we
rented a SUV and I don't know I just
drive man it's the open highways know
what there's rain but whatever want to
try it SUV Jericho's can you slow down
as I look to our family on 110 110
that's too fast
papa side what wait what what you're
high
no huh we're gonna edit that out why you
can't be high nicotine yeah oh and they
could tell ya I don't know I don't smoke
weed dude I don't smoke weed anymore
I thought you're saying you're hot no
never not don't blow anymore no blow no
meth meth deftly off no acid new year's
rival carnage resolution no mental no
more mouths now I'm are mouth no more
missions [ __ ] off with your resolutions
even with you resolution no I feel like
if I make up my mind to do something I
just start then and then that doesn't
matter like I might not like our new
year I mean my brother talked about like
on the road I eat bad because I'm
excited be in the city and everyone you
ever wanted go here go here so we've
always been out like we go to those
places I told my brother we're getting
older we both got tighten it up on the
road so I mean he made a deal to tighten
up on the road and then my I was talking
a little bit yesterday some personal I
can't I don't want thought about but
just business-wise I need to tighten up
2020 I'm so generous and friendly that
it's not that people take advantage of
me but I just you know maybe I'm kind of
here idea you're very generous
I'm very like I'm very forgiving yes and
then I I have this situation going on I
told you're very you're very well one
things that you feel a lot of people
know about you is that you're very you
are very generous and probably you know
I consider myself that were you might be
recklessly generous sometimes right and
there's nothing wrong with it actually
this really isn't I don't mind that and
then you're you are very forgiving in
terms of like yeah and so are you so I
called Joey hey am I being crazy like
excuse me and I I told you I have to
make it but you know I call I say if I
said well you Rogen top film it if I say
that you're not crazy then in that it's
a function it's a problem but I was
tiger in the tall grass in that
situation yeah without giving it up yeah
so yeah my name is Rosie likes pink I'm
just tighten things yeah yeah that makes
sense
I told Todd my guys don't be an absolute
may not be an [ __ ] you've been a
professional
so also here's the other thing some
people are worth a lot of effort some
people aren't and it's it's fine
yeah that's up that's I was doing her
people's feelings yeah so like I just
deal with it it's like let me try
breaking up with a girlfriend took me
four years yes my father said that one
time he said he had fired somebody in
and I was like cheese and he goes but
there's somebody who's waiting and who's
been working luck to Martin and deserves
it yeah you know a lot more I like that
about football like watching hard knocks
and stuff where it's like this is
football this is professional football
you wanna play in the NFL the reason
that we go we play the FL we go we take
a second big deal is because he didn't
fall for all those pitfalls and it's
rare it's [ __ ] rare super maybe I'd
fall on those pitfalls I'm not saying
I'm better yeah but but but yeah you
know that's what happens we all know
that we know that what are we what I say
to you we always talk about this if
you're if you're after something if
you're after something I'll be honest
with yourself you're probably not doing
everything you need to do because what
does the world deal when you when you're
not buttoned down it's done it to me so
I'm speaking from experience he's going
they go oh what's the excuse cool
next that's Olivia can you move by the
way that's awesome I'm sorry about that
can you just move out the way we got
somebody there are 50 people waiting in
line if you might if you don't mind 100%
so it's not how it goes I had this idea
for a business my buddies non-support
makes a lot of money he looked at me he
goes don't do this
I go why yours it's a full-time job this
is this is a rookie talk right now oh
but I do on the positive note resolution
of sights firing everybody now positive
the other positive not you guys you get
just kidding we fired you idea oh my god
we hired your sister out of college yeah
but just don't say anything John
addressed the [ __ ] like your sister
you know she's great um we told we
talked about I don't talk too much but
fine kid 3d ish revamped yeah wheels are
in motion I've been talking about this
yep yep let me start torn together a
little more ah that's the other good
it's gonna be a good lot more high yeah
you're gonna dress me you [ __ ] dress
me I love the dress I get into my fat
lay put this on I don't wanna come on
come here come here
you trust me like a little kid you ever
try to put shoes on a little kid and
this is a few things are harder now my
kids get into the moon and then putting
fitting shoes on a kid's foot when he's
just like man I can't in this [ __ ]
heel oh dude I feel I saw that espionage
movie with Will Smith is a bird the
cartoon task lies in disguise right it's
fantastic especially for parents you
know the movies can be real shitty okay
so me my kid went to that dude he farted
in the theater but you know kids are
just like whatever
yeah dude he farted so loud I could I'm
Toni I thought I was they have to leave
the theater I was laughing so hard so it
was so I'm like are you [ __ ] we're gonna
it's dead science or they're [ __ ]
yeah he just flips this little leg it
was so cute I'm like wow wow dude my son
said not to take a shower for four days
now I wasn't paying attention cuz we're
skiing there like [ __ ] was my mother
comes with us your son hasn't taken a
shower in four days I go huh I'm a great
dad I had that kid I was like
stripped-down attack come on what do you
don't want to say shower I don't give a
[ __ ] either I get the [ __ ] out of your
momma you get a shower let's go and his
whistle his whistle lots of issues cuz
he's gonna go I'm not wife in there
that's properly whatever shot this
movie's legitimate did you see with with
my baby boy offs he's five weeks old he
said he saw pictures get all chubby he's
getting real chubby now and his favorite
thing oh you know they're so young so
it's hard to get a motion at him
but the one thing we know for sure is
will strip him down so he's just in his
[ __ ] diapers and I give him a
full-body massage he smiles so I don't
give them to smile so I'm such a little
fat legs little fat arms there is time I
get home I do it like you do [ __ ] man
man I wish she would sleep done you know
pop was dying I was dying yeah I see
what I would do is just let the let my
lady take care of all that and I just
sleep on through no wake up want to do
and I
how things go to work now
yeah that's a full-time job stuff gig I
love I saw a woman traveling I had to
bring my two niece and nephew and my two
kids on the plane just me just told
Bryan how to check them into because I
was their guardian for my niece and
nephew that's a fun line of waiting and
then it's all good and I saw a woman in
front of me who had a one-year-old a
three-year-old and a seven-year-old and
she was doing it on her own
oh when I see that I'm like oh like yeah
it's just like single parents single
moms it's like Oh single moms have it
hard so hard
there are a lot I would say you know if
I'm flying someone sit in first class if
if I see a single mom with like a baby
I'll give them my seat if you have a kid
yeah and you're a dude but you know your
outer won't take it you know a lot want
take it really yep I'm like hey you can
have my guitar you in the back you can
have my seat Allah won't do it they
think something's up I think I look
creepy I don't know I mean like they
take him and turn me down twice yeah
like no we're good we're back here we
appreciate we're Gillick really yeah
yeah I don't know man it's like I sit in
first class and I make everybody else in
the back is there about you so if you're
a dad I just don't like these [ __ ]
dudes have kids and then they just don't
see their their kids [ __ ] you're you're
a loser you're the definition of a loser
don't do that don't do it man up and
take care of your [ __ ] kids and be
there for them emotionally be there for
them if you don't you're you're a piece
of [ __ ] I'll bet you just miss it out
yeah you're missing out you're missing
out and you're gonna regret it you're
gonna regret it I hope whoever is
listening is they're probably listeners
have done this don't do it do whatever
you have to be in that kid's life and
pay for [ __ ] I don't care if you can't
afford it do it what does he get so I'm
pretty sure you guys have seen this
video it's a video of the pony flapping
away a woman that kept on grabbing at
him he eventually apologized and said
that love makes us patient but that day
he lost his patience and that he
apologizes
ladies McGraw yes it's not agent lady
well it'll get her hooli excited no
she's ready it's always one of us no
they don't always one of us
oh she grabbed him hard yeah what was
she saying though what she grabbed the
gangsta's arm outside I was bad I know
what'd she say yeah I can't really make
it sound Korean I don't think so
you think good a lot of people saw this
video and they were really angry with
the Pope there are people who lured him
to step down my god which I thought is a
lot of people like six people - you know
I buy a lot of people you mean the
[ __ ] done is on Twitter
how about Rose McGowan did you see what
Rose McGowan tweeted after so we killed
this guy Suleiman who is pillow person
yeah he's an architect of the question
is when you take out the most powerful
man in Iran it is it can be considered
an act of war it's a very scary
situation I don't know a little War II
don't I don't but I they said they're
gonna read about how Iran's gonna
retaliate puts it creates a dangerous
situation in Middle East I don't know
enough about I just don't want to I
don't know enough I don't like the way
around in Iraq went I mean I don't like
the way around enough girl I'm sorry
Iraq and Afghanistan went and I'm very
worried about it all this should be but
but at the same time Rose McGowan goes
dear on the USA it's disrespected your
country your flag your people 52% of us
humbly apologize we want we want peace
with your nation we are being held
hostage by a terrorist regime oh no we
do not know how to escape please do not
kill us oh so so so so uh money like so
we do know that this guy was basically
one of the architects of Hezbollah
he was creating the same phenomenon in
Syria and Iraq he was in Baghdad not not
there for American interests he is
directly related to tied to killing
Americans this is a guy who you
politically is not our ally now should
we have killed him both Iraq and both
Bush and Obama held off on doing so it's
a very risky thing to do you're talking
the most successful general tactician
and most powerful man behind the
Khomeini that in in Iran yikes it's a
it's like it's very Italian right
they have two and one with it there's
already a proxy war you know what I mean
by proxy they fight through other you
know cells other ways yeah and so so
Iran and and the United States have
always had an adversarial relationship
this is such a provocation no ever do
you know the US has a second-biggest
Iranian population outside we are huge
we know that yeah but there there is
that's less because most of those your
onions are expats they don't want that
regime they want to have a democratic
Iran so scary yeah it's a very
complicated situation also rose mcgowan
low but also rose rose take it easy
go back to the Harvey Weinstein [ __ ] why
are you tweeting this well ben shapiro
goes oh look the drama students have
something to say you know as an actor i
Twitter I try to stay in form but I try
to keep my mouth shut because this is a
complicated risky I will say though that
there is I believe I I don't trust after
Afghanistan I don't trust our our
leaders very much when it comes to war I
don't trust what they say huh they've
lost my trust however this guy was going
back to Bush to this guy was always
known as the architect there's a reason
why Bush and Obama never did it there's
a risky yeah the nice man that you know
however you're poking at the same time
this guy was what they say he was
planning some some real you know some
real operations he was a mastermind yeah
I don't know I don't know the answer it
makes me very uneasy it you may call
this very idea it really should but but
when you kill you know we cut the head
off of a snake yeah man you be careful
it comes net that's right and sometimes
you get people who are as intelligent
arz rizona
but you know I'll tell you this about
Trump well I've never been a big fan of
he's not a warlike guy he wants to get
he doesn't want to go to war yeah he
wants getting lost he was always saying
that so in that sense I I have to
believe he's not looking for a war but
he was he was
from you know Iranian people I don't do
this man you do this as trouble but
remember also then he was also a guy who
had sent very clear signals that he
didn't want any kind of confrontation
with Iran Iran became very emboldened by
that so when you get remember you're
talking about countries here you're not
talking about people so when you when
you send out a signal that we are not we
are not interested in any kind of
violence and any kind of war Iran is
very active as a proxy very active in
everywhere from Afghanistan to Syria
with the visually they they were they
help the Russians with propping up the
Assad regime I mean in Iraq they've
caused nothing but problems so you know
they they are of a major player in that
part of the world and there always has
to be a balance of power so maybe
hopefully Iran goes holy [ __ ] the US
isn't [ __ ] around now let's all stay
calm they're pretty proud people though
right yeah it's but but they're all the
leadership is also very cold and
calculating and how they behave this is
all there's a lot of showboating to save
face yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] that
they do behind the scenes that yeah
nobody wants a war no no I say Iran I
mean Trump set it aside especially with
you the US no I'm said you wants to
release the US of a hound these yeah and
the US says my ranges are foaming at the
mouth
yeah but you know Iran's a very
different situation yeah very modified
population it's and we don't want that
no I don't want to be killing a lot of
lie to say I don't want to kill no this
to her audience we don't want war know a
lot of Americans scary though well I
thought my god [ __ ] but I think God
knows he's got cops the Rose what would
you say you do besides cry all the time
that ever yeah well would you what did
you say you do well this is did you know
the glory days of her when she was
[ __ ] around with Marilyn Manson and
she was then charmed yeah I was cool she
was beautiful yeah she goes off the deep
end man what else you got yes here's
this wait who is this other one yes
there's another one
ayuh Napa Britain found guilty of a
false rape claim I don't know
I do think she's hot though I do think
Roseman gallons hot still do still do
fail yep okay dude can you imagine right
you can just imagine the toxic that
comes out out of her mouth after you
done better than that laying in bed next
to her oh no oh did I tell you about
[ __ ] Harvey the other day but oh god
Rose McGowan's walk back of her apology
to Iran get slam social media yeah she
apologizes like an emotional person she
was a dime piece though okay so on New
Year's Day the Detroit Fire Detroit Fire
Department posted up this photo of the
firefighters in front of a building
burning it went viral and a lot of
people said some hey obviously not good
and they said one you guys don't know
whether this photo was taken that night
or another night to the home was vacant
and so were the other homes right next
to it the other two they were both
vacant so everyone was safe but people
are still very upset that they posted up
a photo of them in front of a burning
house there's a bear a better looks to
be happy yeah I love firefighters god
bless them all they're better looks me
up I would have said guys but also who
cares yeah their firefighters you know
see if they keep your communal nowadays
lost so it's like with social media now
this is the day when everybody has a
point of view and you have to listen to
it nowadays everybody here has a nice
voice their point everyone's and that's
right that's right
but yeah now their fire commissioner is
under investigation because of this
photo
oh yeah he's gonna ask our case but I
mean again this isn't real I'm sure if
you went to Detroit in the stitch right
in Detroit and asked the people of
Detroit doing that we don't care yeah
whatever but not social media and you
know oh my god he always everyone live
in [ __ ] yeah Florida can you believe
it who has nothing to do with that you
know real people aren't tweeting this
yeah what else you got yes
one more one more - bad luck everybody
it's funny though it's funny hey boys
ask it together snap pick for this house
turns into ashes we're oh you got a pic
together
- it's already too far gone it's also
[ __ ] these houses though right let it
burn it's also Detroit ashes each
actually enjoyed a quick question though
before we go to the next one what is a
deadlift exactly what is verses like a
cleaner so the bars on the ground you
you bend down you grab it and you lift
it your lifts as literal as you're
lifting up deadly yes what are you doing
what did I do
mm-hmm why chin why is that important
it's it's it's one of the one of the
best measures for how strong you are how
strong saving that so it's the best
thing you do for a full body mmm what's
a clean clean is this why chin because
I'm trying to understand the difference
okay okay yep there's he and then a
snatch is overhead that's what he did
yeah that's a clean and the snatches you
go there but overhead yep gotcha
beautiful all right last one is just the
you talked about Elizabeth Hurley's son
before that he's a very beautiful person
right I don't know maybe talk about is
hot as mom I don't know he he posted the
holiday picture with his mother and they
look almost exactly alike actually
pretty amazing judge of this chick Azad
how amazing is that
that's her son Damian is that little
haze I did that's what that's the first
thing I thought of - this is the kind of
look that is a gorgeous that looks like
little haze without the right words as
human being
oh god there's more pictures I'll talk
about Jack's okay Wow but this is the
most recent one that he posted on his
Jesus Christ this piercing blue that
mouth skin god she's a beautiful he's a
good-looking
he looks more feminine than her he does
right well that might be his whole thing
yeah there you go
holy [ __ ] look at those lips yeah he's
got a very soft that you could be let me
see let me see this money as younger mmm
but now you know don't go to this big
Provo see that's the most recent one
with his mom oh she's obviously just
doing the there you go yeah he's he
looks like he's embracing his very
feminine sort of he's a model now in an
erogenous look yes Perry why not
that's when he was like well I'm not
saying I like I'm attracted to it I'm
not saying I like I have a fantastic
boner right now but other than that I
think he's young it's the guy that left
his number on the airplane you know that
was him
no I he looks like older probably that's
a good question looks like he's at least
18 nice old I don't know what you look
like don't throw up 17 all right I
didn't realize that I mean it is going
through he's going through some stuff
here yeah I mean what do you mean goes
nothing wrong why is he going through
stuff just amazing Jade ooh he looks so
much like his mom he's just like he's
enjoying his beauty yes he looks so much
like his mom yeah he's enjoying his
beauty yeah now do they not have a
daughter I don't know
I would imagine he's definitely probably
music hey genius oh you think Sherlock
you never know but they said as straight
as a goddamn San Francisco Road dude
he's not straight I'm sure look at that
blowout and some head set of hair on him
there's no daughter though Elizabeth
Hurley daughter yeah how many kids yeah
I think she only has one child I think
it's just him
oh let's get us here what a gorgeous
woman oh that was on a show oh gosh dude
Bill Clinton flooring it looks likes
just her son to hang out yeah old
scalawag uh-huh Wow good for him better
work that would be worth yeah just a son
lose any job over here Aaron that's and
she's English fussing she was good
everything food wine gums and a dicksuck
cup a proper cup of tea with milk and
sugar suck I'd love to get a proper cup
of tea I'm an England dude in May oh my
get some tea I'm gonna team gimmick do
my wine gums yeah yeah in fact licorice
oh yeah dude fish and chips and a
[ __ ] oh god I love it Nashville come
see me January 10 and 11
Cleveland January 30 31 hello everyone
hilarity Club well my favorite clubs
can't wait ah next Friday I'm in
Connecticut Foxwoods casino and then I'm
driving on down to Boston Wilbur theater
less than 50 tickets left Boston Wilbur
theater and then San Jose January 17th
through the 19th San Jose improv that's
a Friday Saturday Sunday at the San Jose
improv Friday Saturday Sunday and then
Charlotte Jesus Christ Charlotte comedy
zone Charlotte January 23rd through the
25th and then Columbus Ohio uh t-bone
Columbus Ohio cat - please tell your
sister and her friends Lee they get
tickets VIP Hotel Columbus Ohio January
31st through February 1st and there's
dates all over the place after that tea
fat K calm but next weekend Connecticut
Foxwoods Boston Wilbur get your tickets
t pack a calm
Brian anything else Thanks ranks this
the fine kid